[Musique]
des rires les yeux braqués sur un écran
d'ordinateur
il passe ainsi des heures gili anna
miquel geoffrey est clos et chemine de
blog en blog sur internet
moi je vais ce que je meure
principalement leur blog puisqu'on est
dans la même classe donc sécher mes
copains ou que j'aime bien les charrier
j'aime bien me charrier donc en général
ça reste que ça reste dans notre cercle
leur donne une chaire club à 17 ans
chloé comme plus d'un million et demi
d'adolescents a créé son propre blog
il y a quelques mois blogue un terme
anglais qui désigne ces pages
personnelles aux allures de journaux
intimes que l'on trouve sur internet un
mode d'expression dont les ados se sont
emparés guidé par une radio qui leur est
destinée il ya plein de choses
c'est des photos de moments que j'ai des
bons moments que j'ai passés que ce soit
avec ma famille dans mon sport avec mes
amis donc j'ai envie de le faire
partager donc je mets les photos et des
petits commenté un côté et les gens y
mettent des commentaires ne nous disent
nous charries aussi peuvent ils peuvent
émettre des commentaires pour pour nos
bus clients un peu c'est aussi le but
mais bon après c'est ça en met une photo
nous faut accepter la critique après
mais aussi on réagit on va sur leur blog
et à nos tours hanotaux on les bouscule
aussi voir des photos d'amis de famille
ou de stars y allait de son petit
commentaire c'est pour ça qu'une guérite
parcours ces pages il ya quelques
semaines elle s'est rendue sur un blog
consacré à son collège début d'épreuve
qui me faisait rire donc ça m'a j'ai mis
du commun il aime bien ensuite j'ai vu
une preuve que j'aimais pas moi j'étais
un peu moins gentil donc je me suis un
peu plus lâché mais j'ai pas ça m'a même
étonnée moi-même j'ai pas mis insulte un
billet d'humeur qui lui vaut très vite
une convocation chez le principal
ailleurs après des plaintes
d'enseignants des élèves sont exclus le
blog terre de libre expression des
adolescents suscite les inquiétudes des
parents d'un seul coup ça passe sur la
place publique d'un seul coup
effectivement il ya des gens qui se sont
blessé qui se sentent offensés et c'est
vrai que est bien seul coup on a réalisé
que il pouvait y avoir de l'irrespect
qui pouvait y avoir des atteintes à la
personne sans intention volontaire de le
donner comme c'est pas encore bien
réglementé finalement et qui a pas
encore soit des chartes des choses comme
ça qui statuerait un peu sur
l'utilisation qu'on peut faire de ce
type d'outil donc ouais ça nous on est
dépassé way faire des câlins le
phénomène est en pleine expansion
chaque jour 200 mille photos ou textes
sont ainsi publié via internet par les
jeunes blogueurs
[Musique]